joining us now is South Carolina
Congresswoman Nancy mace take a look at
this first the Biden family
needs her for this
we've done the work for them so they
can't screw it up now at these
allegations any of these allegations are
proven true than someone with the last
name Biden needs to be charged
prosecuted maybe spend a little time in
prison to take to account and
responsible for the actions they've
taken today all right joining us now
with more South Carolina Congresswoman
Nancy mace is with us I agree they do
need to get off their ass and then they
need to get to the bottom of this it's
interesting because Congressman Comer
the chairman earlier in the week said to
the doj Do Not indict Hunter Biden and
is the reason for that that you now
believe that the committee is getting
far deeper into the Biden family and
their business dealings with foreign
Nations especially hostile Nations and
it runs a lot deeper than what they
would charge Hunter Biden with
yes that is the case and I will tell you
this is as you say Sean everything you
said was a hundred percent true and this
is just the tip of the iceberg and here
we have a doj and FBI who are who are
indicting Trump on misdemeanors and then
will not investigate Biden for betraying
his country and I have to tell you
absolutely no one can accuse me of being
hyper partisan or being in the tank for
Donald Trump but good Lord the amount of
evidence in this case is ridiculous they
weren't hiring Hunter Biden for his
brains they weren't hiring certainly
Hunter Biden for his Braun they were
hiring him to pay for access to the
White House and we see this pattern
repeat itself over and over and over
again the reports that we saw at the
treasury would appear to be racketeering
that comes to mind money laundering wire
fraud why were they able to enrich
themselves with tens of millions of
dollars including as you say a
grandchild nieces and nephews current
wives Ex-Wives a brother a son you name
it and the list goes on that family tree
is very very big and they made a lot of
money off of Joe Biden you know we
talked this week's a lot about Romania
and about China and that was only part
of the China story but there's one story
that we have uh full understanding of
and that is is barisma the oil and gas
giant in Ukraine and Joe Biden leveraged
one billion taxpayer dollars and said
you're not getting it until you fire a
prosecutor in Ukraine who it turns out
was looking into baristma and into
Hunter Biden Hunter Biden had gone on
Good Morning America admitted he had no
experience at all whatsoever in Ukraine
oil energy gas nothing so the question
then remains Joe had to know that this
guy was looking into his son that
facilitated even further payments
because the investigation stopped and
Joe Biden leveraged a billion taxpayer
dollars to do it is that an impeachable
crime in your view
well if the evidence proves that out
then it would be and you're looking at a
President Who time and time again has
lied to the American people I call them
the balls and Strikes Sean whether you
have an r or D by your name and it is
outrageous that this has gone unchecked
by the mainstream media it's insane let
me interrupt for a second Joe Biden is
on tape bragging that he leveraged that
billion dollars Hunter Biden is on Good
Morning America admitting he had no
experience at all but we know he was
getting paid all this money what more
what in terms of evidence what more
evidence would you need
well I love the Constitution and due
process it'll be up to us to show the
American people of doj won't do its job
we'll do their job for them but to show
the evidence that we get by our
investigation by the bank records and we
only got the bank records of four Banks
they're up to a dozen maybe more when we
looked at the reports at the treasury we
were only looking at reports for two of
the bidens come to find out there are
nine of them there is a lot of
investigating that we have to do to
prove our case that that would be an
impeachable offense you got to have the
evidence before you can do that and we
ought to show that the American Peach
Bowl can trust us with the evidence that
we collect how many countries do you
believe ultimately are involved here and
how many more llc's do you think might
exist out there well we know of over 20
llc's right now and I think there are
dozens of countries countries around the
world these were our adversaries this
was communist China buying access to the
White House and when you look at for
example when you look at the revolving
door of the records of the White House
the plane trips that Hunter Biden has
taken with his father as president and
vice president and you add it all up and
it is corruption of the highest order
the most political the most Corruption
of any uh and of anyone in American
politics is what I think it will end up
being what about this 1023 form request
that the committee made to the doj and
the FBI and so far they are unwilling to
give it over to the committee what's
your reaction to that well I believe
that it shows the that the evidence
exists the document exists that it is
true and certain members of the
committee have had their eyeballs on it
and I want us I want the American people
to see this documentation even if the
FBI wants to bury it sunshine is the
best medicine let's bring it to light
show the American people what's really
been going on all right congresswoman
thank you we appreciate you being with
us hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else